all right it's back in town but much
much much much much much better
all right now my name's herb aha welcome
back to some more and rise of nightmare
all right let's go
am I supposed to copy this I don't get
[Music]
yeah I can
oh damn tight hey hey oh wait that's
ugly echoes Josh sorry alright there we
go okay so you were dead to the world
wow that was looking at baby listen what
I want to talk to you about Taliban I'm
totally listening I don't trust them
Josh that is not mine what I'm sorry
girl what is it
I didn't mean you should start fighting
it and I'm sorry I give my damn I hate
sounding like a nagging wife well then
but I've been putting up with this for
five years when do you grow up God hey
girl how you doin
oh I want to make this work Josh but I
can't with you at the bottom of the
bottle okay I'm sorry I'm changed wow I
can't do this right now
Thank You Kate oh no Katie does go play
hold on I'm really drunk
all right side way I can't see yeah you
said it the drinking brah
yeah splash of cold water
alright let's go into the bathroom I
trained a little bit so I should be
better but I mean I can't
you can open pause menu by holding your
life bar alright I don't need to know
that all right and to the right Alex yes
examine your cavity that's how I open
doors and i-20 we got this looks like
matter
Oh Oh chop Nelnet alright
why do you have to do this come on holy
[ __ ]
I don't even but the [ __ ] is that holy
[ __ ] that's get me can't dammit alright
fine Kate that was a total condom copy
but it looks like your socks awara roach
what is it
are you hitting on my wife I stop here I
slap you hey come in let's love you I
shot you for disrespecting me alright
fine
how do I open what am I supposed to do
okay wait right here have it huh touch
touch
I let it pick up so I don't I got angry
I'm not myself she printed it out meet
me in the dining car right it doesn't
really make sense but Dad Kano's I can't
put my arm there never again alright
where the [ __ ] is that already
disappeared let's go
all right Oh fun silly door that's right
nice guy Oh
that's right what is this place hey
girls I didn't know what and I go
forward son of them
what what am i doing
now what did they do there we go
made it shut up
it's not that funny okay
[ __ ] yeah I'm a party ah I'm not - all
you got these most oh I thought you'd
say that I snuck in
there's the only one I got yeah [ __ ]
yeah raining it out man
alright alright alright
open it that's right
by Hannegan ha ha let's [ __ ] you then
I'm exhausted for another 8 dancing but
now that they're sorry it's ok
Oh Sophia Trail cars [ __ ] like chops
your Burmese yeah is it everyone in this
game have an accent
alright ok then it I interact now yeah
McCullough Tory and then [ __ ] did she go
have to go so far
what now I in my way server let's see
you thinking I don't have a ticket
oh [ __ ] this is not goodness you can't
burst without your tea
well can you [ __ ] go in the Edit what
well hello there girl
why is everyone starting with me fine
alright this now she's in the dining
cart I don't have to do this flip but
Flo I don't give a [ __ ] just okay thank
you
you love your wife and she
thank you
[Music]
haha corn after town all of these
this is your probably shut up somewhere
you have lost your way with my drinking
I'm sorry
don't worry okay we still have hope
you're here to uh my fear 10-q check I
gave me something good Christian oh no
the Buddhist no no what is that
no what's happening with it is Oh
Buddhist No
[Music]
okay post 30 brah can I go that can have
the ticket
stupid there you go god damn that was a
waste of time
yeah blow mine okay these fortune
tellers always predict to doom and gloom
don't even come - okay step aside
I need to go alright kappa where the
[ __ ] is this dining card it's been
forever literally alright ha-cha-cha
well we have a reach the dining cart
[Music]
what is she doing no there's no problem
it's also being stuffed by mid-week
get out of my way out of my way
do you mind I'm walking yeah don't yeah
me sidestep watch ah that's how I wrote
me after you I'm not that Americans
yes I'm us with their fan all right
where is my wife let's find her come on
man
all right here we go now I gotta get to
this thing oh my god so much work oh my
gosh it's so many I'm tired
why is there blood on that thing [ __ ]
jump stairs man don't fall all right
thank you
ha hey Rosie the gun all right oh hey
bag how you done oh [ __ ] a lotta blood
may be a period party instead of there a
party ha ha
but inch that was funny what and wasn't
they I don't shoot that dirty ass to me
whoa
bro smack how much I hated that one nice
going yeah and his name is aunt
[Music]
what is that your boyfriend
alright that was pretty [ __ ] crazy
and I should scares me
I'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ] all right I'm
ready here let me see if I can like a
favorite kept gettin guy
[Music]
it's a robot you are a go